foreign  it was that very morning  went on his way to nottingham and  passing through sherwood forest  that robin knelt before richard the  lionheart and declared i would rather  keep the law and do good than live  outside the law  for you are my lord and my king  the end  good night buddy good night buddy  [Music]  how long were you listening  long enough to know that i feel more for  you than i realized  and i don't know what i would have done  if you hadn't offered to help you would  have thought of something  why don't i go get us dinner from the  salute i'd offered a cook but i have to  admit that sounds pretty nice  i'll be right back  [Music]  you